[Music]
it's been almost six years since the
last number dirt game but we'll be
getting the fourth later this year
that's right codemasters has officially
announced turd for I'm Matt and this is
your off-roading gamespot news update in
its announcement codemasters said that
dirt for takes the passion and
authenticity of off-road racing to the
next level while also reintroducing you
to white-knuckle truck and buggy racing
and dirt for will apparently put an
emphasis on the dangers of motorsport
we're not exactly sure what this means
but we expect that it'll be fast cars
driving on treacherous paths thankfully
it's a video game so we don't have to
worry about actually driving off a cliff
codemasters also talked about a new
feature called your stage which lets you
create rally stages that you can race
and share with your friends dirt for
releases for ps4 xbox one and pc in june
there aren't many confirmed details but
we'll report back when further
information is revealed so for that and
more from the world of video games stay
tuned to GameSpot's